foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear once again
so
I feel like the term elevated horror has
been thrown around quite a bit in the
last decade or so maybe more than that
um but you know obviously anybody that
knows anything about horror knows that
you know what they call elevated horror
it's not really a new phenomenon uh you
know you've had Art House style horror
that's existed probably as long as the
genre itself has
um and in my opinion I'm gonna say that
I think horror is probably the best
genre available for when you want to
maybe like explore some uncomfortable
philosophical truths or some dark
realities or something in a way that's
maybe more like impactful or insightful
for the person watching it
um I kind of feel like because you're
taking things that are maybe unpleasant
to think about or like really
devastating emotions that you don't
really want to unpack within yourself
um and placing them into the context of
a supposedly unreal horror film like
place things at one remove you know in
that unreal scenario maybe might make
the actual emotions that play much
easier to process much easier to digest
much easier to get a handle on so I
think that horror movies in that way can
be like really cathartic and can like
open up you know discussions about like
I said stuff that maybe people don't
necessarily want to uh think about you
know now obviously Art House horror
isn't for everyone and it doesn't
necessarily have to be I mean people
like what they like and I don't really
like to [ __ ] on people for having
different uh proclivities or different
preferences or whatever
but I will say that for those who
like to maybe explore the harsher
extremes
of of horror there are always kind of
challenging films out there that are
available to fit the bill whatever you'd
uh like to explore and oh boy is the
1981 film possession one of those movies
now this movie it's kind of like I don't
know if I want to say it's like
notorious but it was banned in the UK
for quite a long time they put it on the
video nasties list which
is a little bit strange like I get why
they did it and it was actually like
really hard to get hold of for a very
long time uh happily shutter just added
it and I think they also did like a
really nice Blu-ray release of it
recently as well the movie was also got
a limited release in the US but was
heavily edited from its original two
hours down to 81 minutes for the US
release they took out like essentially
like a third of the movie which is why
it maybe didn't get great reviews at the
time because a lot of the context of the
story was lost
now although I will say that possession
isn't
really super gory or super violent in
the way that maybe you might be thinking
like maybe in this in the way that like
some of the other video nasties were
like maybe Lucia full Chi's movies or
like the Cannibal Holocaust type movies
or something like that I mean don't get
me wrong possession is you know does
have a lot of blood and it's very
visceral and there is a lot of violence
in it but I kind of think this one just
comes more what's disturbing about this
one is just how uncomfortable it is to
watch like just I don't know just like
the emotions that that it explores it's
very very Primal it's very raw and so I
think it's more that I think it's more
the concept the idea behind it the way
it's presented more than it is any
particular like like graphic sexual or
violent content you know what I'm saying
now the movie isn't entirely realistic
but I wouldn't really call it surreal
either it's kind of more it's largely
realistic but it's more like exaggerated
or maybe like hyper real
um and it's clearly very metaphorical
also and it's also open to multiple
interpretations now when it was released
uh it was often compared to the works of
Roman Polanski and David Cronenberg
usually to repulsion and The Brood most
specifically
and it was also a very obvious influence
on a number of more recent films you
know films that came afterward uh like
the 2018 Suspiria remake
um Antichrist from 2009 the large Von uh
Trier movie and um the 2018 movie climax
uh Gaspar no way so this is a very like
influential film
so in other words if you are at all
interested in any of those movies or
those kinds of movies and haven't seen
possession you really need to get on it
because it's definitely a unique film
experience that's for sure and whether
you love it or hate it because I kind of
feel like you're either gonna be one
extreme or the other I don't think that
you will ever forget it that is
definitely for sure so possession was
actually the only English language film
uh made by a Polish filmmaker named
Andres Andres zolovski who just died in
2016 I believe
and the concept for it was kind of came
out of he he went through this really
really horrible uh divorce in 1976 uh
from his wife who was an actress named
malgorzada broneck I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that right but hopefully I'm
kind of close
so the movie then is essentially of just
this bizarre and kind of Highly symbolic
account of the breakdown of a marriage
and the spiral into madness that's maybe
engendered by the breakdown but there's
so much more going on in the story that
it's kind of like difficult to pin it
down to just one thing so the movie
takes place in West Berlin and much as
in uh the Suspiria remake from 2018 the
Berlin Wall uh looms very large in the
narrative uh as a symbol of I mean in
this case probably representing division
descent and maybe like the close
proximity of evil how it's always just
like right there like just beyond the
barrier so Sam Neal is in this this was
a fairly early role for him
and he plays a guy named Mark who's some
kind of international spy and he's just
returned from some shady Espionage
operation someplace after kind of an
undisclosed but you're led to believe
very lengthy amount of time
so to his superiors citing family
reasons he's basically like well you
know you guys need to appoint my
successor because he essentially wants
to retire from the Espionage game and
doesn't want to like do it anymore
however Upon returning home uh to his
wife Anna who's played by Isabella
Johnny in an award-winning and
rightfully so performance because holy
crap this is one of the most probably
like Fearless acting performances that
I've ever seen so Mark discovers that
Anna is not real enthused about his
return uh she basically is like yeah um
I need some more time apart from you
even though he's been gone a really long
time and he only just got back so she's
presumably had a lot of time apart from
him like up to now but apparently that
still wasn't enough
so finally she tells him that she wants
a divorce
and he asks her you know oh has she been
seeing somebody else now at first she
denies it uh now Mark does actually
admit that he hasn't been entirely
faithful to her either but you know it's
kind of like a double standard thing
where he's kind of like mad about it but
you know you know what I mean it's that
kind of thing
so the couple actually have a son named
Bob
and initially Anna keeps Bob at the
couple's apartment and then Mark moves
into what looks like a hotel of some
kind and he seems to go off on this like
three week Bender of like drinking and
emotional turmoil and crying and stuff
like that that he seems to remember very
little of like after the end of it so
finally snapping out of this Mark goes
back to the apartment and finds out
that Anna has just been out and about
and kind of essentially like neglecting
their son like their son is left in the
house alone and he's just like sitting
there covered with Jam or whatever uh
incidentally this uh event in the movie
was based on a real life incident that
happened to the director like during the
course of the breakup of the marriage I
guess he came home and found their kid
like all covered with Jam because the
mom was out doing whatever she was doing
so Mark then finds out that Anna
actually did lie to him before and that
she had actually been seeing someone
else for quite a long time
and the person that she's seeing is this
kind of suave [ __ ] named
Heinrich who's kind of he's kind of like
a new agey Guru type of dude where he's
just like all about using sex and drugs
like to expand the mind's Horizons man
like that kind of [ __ ]
um so it's implied I don't even know if
it's implied it might be stated outright
uh that basically Heinrich has been able
to sexually satisfy Anna maybe in a way
that Mark never could and it's also kind
of further said that Heinrich supposedly
um accepts Anna the way she is rather
than trying to impose his own idealized
version of her like onto the real woman
which is what you're led to believe that
that Mark has been doing
and as if it's not bad enough that Mark
has basically been being made into like
an unwitting cuckold like by this man by
Heinrich he also when he goes over there
to confront the dude he also like
Heinrich also like hands his ass to him
like pretty handily so you know he just
beats the crap out of him so you know
that's just like adding insult to injury
at this point so yeah the relationship
between Mark and Anna is extremely toxic
to say the least
on the one hand uh Mark does seem to be
afraid that Anna's sanity is beginning
to disintegrate and that her Madness is
essentially starting to become like a
danger to their son and to be fair this
does seem to be a legitimate concern
because she does seem to be losing her
marbles on the other hand though Mark
doesn't really appear to give much of a
crap about their son either and his
whole thing is that he mostly wants to
he seems to just want to control Anna
and fit her into the mold of what he
would like her to be
now Anna for her part
um she seems to be trying to escape what
to her seemed like the very constricting
roles of wife and mother and this
frustration she feels at being unable to
escape this is kind of like um fueling
her I guess like heightening derangement
I guess
it's also suggested maybe that her
ambivalence toward her family toward her
role as wife and mother is causing her a
great deal of guilt and this in turn is
kind of like feeding into this sort of
constant back and forth between her and
Mark like she flees to go be with
Heinrich but then keeps coming back to
the apartment like to see their son and
then like her and Mark will get into it
they'll become involved in these violent
screaming matches and these often end up
with physical violence like he'll start
like popping her around and self-harm
like at one point she you know cuts
herself in the neck like with an
electric knife and all this other kind
of stuff so it's like I said it's not
it's a very very volatile and it's a
really really very very toxic and
unhealthy relationship the two of them
have but they can't seem to just cleanly
part ways you know what I mean
particularly because they have a son and
that's kind of like a you know a
complicating Factor now Mark who seems
to be at least to some extent aware that
the relationship between these two is
poisonous pretty much
um but seems also like obsessed with
possessing her uh hence the title of the
film which like I said is kind of a
multi-layered uh word
he hires a private investigator to
follow her around and like see what
she's up to
meanwhile while this is all going on
he's also started to become sort of
intrigued with his son's school teacher
his name is Helen who's also played by
Isabella Johnny uh so Helen looks pretty
much since it's the same actress looks
pretty much exactly like Anna other than
having kind of like lighter colored hair
and green eyes instead of Anna having
blue eyes I think she has blue eyes or
dark eyes I can't remember but um
Helen's eyes are like super super bright
green now it's not clear in the context
of the movie whether Helen just happens
to very closely resemble Anna or whether
Mark is so wrapped up in His image of
Anna that he essentially perceives Every
Other Woman Who interests him as another
version of her I assume that's probably
like the it's probably the latter thing
but I mean either way it's very very
unhealthy and it's also a little bit uh
unnatural I'm gonna say so the private
investigator who follows Anna discovers
that she has
a terrible Secret
and it's right here where the movie
takes a turn into
batshit quasi lovecraftian body horror
territory okay
because Anna you see has
ostensibly birthed a sort of tentacled
monster that you're not entirely sure if
it's real or not you're led to believe
that it's real but like I said in the
context of the movie it doesn't really
matter one with the other but this
tentacled monster that she has given
birth to
um she has sex with it and she feels the
need to protect it like at all costs
now this monster which according to
whatever interpretation of the film you
want to go with um I've seen it called
maybe it's a physical manifestation of
her guilt at neglecting her son like her
motherhood role or it's a physical
manifestation of just the general evil
like present within her or I've even
seen it called maybe it's a
representation of God or of the
Antichrist which you know there's an
argument to be made for that too which I
think was actually like quite good but
this monster kind of slowly transforms
as the movie goes on and Anna resorts to
violent and very very gruesome murder uh
whenever somebody uncovers its existence
so she ultimately reveals to mark that
while he was away on his last job
presumably
she suffered what she termed a
miscarriage
and this is where we're led to believe
like the seeds of this monster like
originated from this miscarriage scene
like would because they kind of show it
like as a sort of flashback I guess like
while she's telling him about it is
easily the most famous scene in the
movie
um because this whole this whole
sequence is just a tour de force of just
primal
daring just intensely physical acting
Isabella Johnny Goes completely balls to
the wall insane for just this one long
five plus minute take she's just
shrieking and writhing and [ __ ] just
down and around filth and it's just like
it's horrifying to watch and she's just
expelling blood and just white fluid
which could be semen could be mother's
milk could be lots of different things
like from all of her orifices I mean
watching her you absolutely believe that
this is a woman who is legitimately
losing her mind like right like on the
screen right in front of your face and
um Isabella Johnny like later said that
it actually took her several years to
get over the emotional toll that this
film took on her which I believe it like
seeing this movie I could totally
believe it I mean but holy hell her
performance is just terrifying and you
really have to give her it's like it's
almost it's so over the top and so raw
and like so visceral role that it's like
it's almost it goes on so long and it's
just so outrageous that it's almost
funny but then like it just keeps going
it keeps going and then it just becomes
like [ __ ] horrific again you know
what I mean but so I mean you really
really have to give her [ __ ] mad
respect for just going there I mean you
don't usually see an actor's performance
that's like this where someone was just
willing to just go all the way like this
and it's just amazing to watch so anyway
like um once Mark is kind of confronted
with the reality of the monster and also
the horrible things that Anna has
perpetrated in its defense like all the
murders she's committed he actually
decides that I guess in a way he's kind
of gonna like throw in his lot with her
like protecting her the way she protects
the monster because he ends up like
killing Heinrich himself like kind of
making it look like an accident or an
overdose or something and also starts to
help Anna like in covering up her crimes
now along the way his relationship with
Helen who's like Anna's doppelganger
also starts to kind of Blossom a little
bit and we're led to believe I don't
know if this is because like I said this
there's lots of interpretation to this
film and none of them are necessarily
wrong but I was of the opinion that were
led to assume that Helen you know the
the doppelganger is at her core like
Mark's perfect vision of Anna like she
looks almost exactly like her but is
very maternal and very nurturing and
kind of sweet and kind of submissive
and not like just this difficult shrill
bellicose just ball of rage that Anna is
so
it it's so that I think that's kind of
like one of the themes of the movie and
there's that's why there's like a lot of
doubles and stuff like that it's just
because
this is Mark's idealized version of his
wife like he wants the woman that looks
like her but not like that acts like her
he's not willing to just accept her the
way she is you know what I mean and as
the movie like reaches the climax like
the end the theme of doubles or
doppelgangers like really comes into
sharper Focus because it turns out that
when the creature that Anna has been
cultivating I guess reaches its final
form it turns out that it's Mark it's
like a dead ringer for Mark only with
different colored eyes and kind of like
a slightly different demeanor like less
controlling so much like Helen is what
Mark wishes Anna was the monster is
essentially like Anna's idealized
version of Mark so I kind of read this
as the tragedy the whole story being
that this couple could never accept each
other for who they actually were like
just flaws than all but it just kept
insisting on projecting their own needs
and desires onto the other uh and this
just kept having devastating results so
at the end of the movie when The Mark
monster the mark doppelganger goes back
to the apartment and like knocks on the
door and Helen goes to answer it even
though the son Bob is there and he's
like terrified and he keeps saying don't
open don't open don't like don't open
the door
um but she's kind of like she has to
she's like she can't resist it
um and as she goes to let the monster
inside the house we hear what sounds
like a battle like going on outside the
apartment because like I said there's
like a whole like sociopolitical thing
going on too like with the whole like uh
you know Berlin Wall thing so you kind
of hear what sounds like just planes
going over and screaming and bombs and
[ __ ] like that and gunfire and then Bob
runs the kid runs upstairs and appears
to drown himself in the bathtub um
you're led to believe perhaps to escape
the devastation of this horrible
pernicious relation ship that like I
said the two of them can't part from one
another they just have this kind of like
[ __ ] up thing where they can't be
apart but it's like when they're
together it just causes Devastation like
all around them because they can't just
be with one another the way they're
always like projecting their own things
onto the other person and it's just like
really really unhealthy so as I kind of
alluded to earlier
possession is
easily as divisive a film as you're ever
likely to encounter um it's very in your
face it's very combative it's exhausting
to watch and um it just features like so
so much screaming oh my gosh just so
much screaming
um
he you have no idea ever screaming into
this movie
um all of the emotions in it are very
like overwrought very hyperbolic very
operatic and that's really kind of done
on purpose I guess because
I'm I'm guessing what they were going
for was that the interior perceptions of
the characters are kind of like
manifesting externally you know what I
mean as these just exaggerated
extravagant body movements and like just
animalistic howling and stuff like that
because it's like like I said this is
not a surrealistic movie but it is a
hyper real kind of movie where it's just
kind of like
the the character's subjective
experiences like them going through this
divorce even though from the outside if
you were seeing it in the real world
maybe it didn't seem as devastating or
it didn't seem like as big a deal but to
them it really was and so the way that
they're acting and the way that the
movie goes you're seeing their
internalized emotions I guess like
portrayed on screen so everything is
just over like just super super
heightened everyone's like screaming and
punching and it's just like this big
huge thing and like I said it was done
on purpose because you know that you're
manifesting their interior feelings like
externally so all the actors in This are
incredible
um and you know as I mentioned Isabella
Johnny in particular heard I mean it's
just an astonishing book of performance
like I said that somebody would just
[ __ ] go there like that uh the
cinematography in this is also really
amazing it really kind of reinforces the
movie's themes
um because the camera at times is just
very intrusive or it's like these
chaotic movements and a lot of times
like particularly in the early scenes
with you know before everything just
goes like completely batshit crazy like
the way that Mark and Anna like the
characters are framed like you know the
way that they're situated inside the
frame and it really kind of like just um
highlights how fractured they are so uh
it's there's a lot of thought put into
the way everything is framed and laid
out uh so the movie is just it's very
outlandish it's very stylized it's very
strange it's kind of like less a movie I
mean it's a movie but it's less a movie
than it is like an experience you know
what I mean so I'm gonna say if you have
any interest at all in filmmaking just
as a pure art form and in particular
really enjoy kind of challenging not
gonna lie unpleasant a cinema like this
because this isn't a fun movie to watch
like don't so I'm just warning you ahead
of time right now it's not a good time
uh it's gonna like bring you out like
emotionally probably but if you're into
that kind of stuff and if you're in the
mood for it if you're really up for that
kind of experience then this is
absolutely a must-see and you know like
I said it's a cult classic for a reason
and if you you have any interest at all
in you know some of the newer kind of
more extreme type of films then this is
one that you should see because it was
really really influential so that will
do it for this flickers of fear I'll see
you guys again on the next one bye
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]